a gigantic football cleat in the German
and French national colours welcomes
visitors to any alabbar a picturesque
spa town on Lake Geneva this is where
the members of the German national team
will be based during euro 2016 kach
welcome live and his team will be
staying at the hotel lav natash built in
1909 it overlooks the lake during the
championship the entire hotel is
reserved for the squad hotel manager
uniquely egg is looking forward to
hosting the Germans syphilis and organ
is also complement something like this
doesn't happen every day to be honest
we're really proud the four-star hotel
has many advantages super saved us this
area is very very safe with the lake on
one side and the mountains on the other
and the hotel is surrounded by nature
which is great you get the feeling
you're in the woods you can hear the
birds and we have a 15 hectares in dicta
a hotel also has a very friendly
family-oriented atmosphere which is what
they were looking for inovio and more
radio famiiy bassano del de familia the
players hotel suites look out onto
either the lake or the forest
Yannick lejacq is heading to the dining
hall the hotel's master chef will work
together with the football squads own
cook when's your due i SPECT e che dear
Kady shall believe men you kiss the
players are high performers and so we
need to cook the kind of meals they
require a key or bizarre or lean with
their top athletes the need food that
will allow them to win that simple idea
the hotel has plenty of facilities to
help players chill out between matches a
billiard table a bar and even an indoor
pool and just one kilometer away lies
the Kami Lumiere football stadium where
the German players can train the town of
ideale bar has exciting events in store
for Euro 2016
the notion plus book we've organized
football themed entertainment for kids
and the general public on weekends
during the European Championships up at
the kamir only a stadium you'll be able
to watch the squad train every day and
we've established a press center nearby
with space for 300 journalists windows
are decked out with football decorations
and a local pizzeria even has a German
language menu for the fans novica
mubarak de la vieja l'amour de our bar
will offer German beer and we'll try to
show all the european championship
matches and hope that it attracts
customers when I stopped after a seafood
euro 2016 is an opportunity for German
and French people to get to know one
another better
sure sequel Coco pleased that the German
team is here it's good for the town it
will bring some enthusiasm to this
reserved place come on campus tomorrow
to jasmine sigh my taillights papas good
I'm not interested in all this football
is mostly about business and making
money the town of Evian can be pleased
to have such important guests you see yo
sak regle via it'll liven up this town
and change every on a little it's
exciting to host an international team
euro 2016 is a big deal for every alley
bar and the residents are well prepared
for it